on en débat tout de suite avec nos
invités à des rimes belghiti professeurs
et secrétaire général du sgen cfdt
lorraine et jean-paul salle
infectiologues au chu de grenoble
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce soir sur rtl france les écoles
donc il reste fermé en moselle dans le
nord aussi à dunkerque malgré la
circulation active des variants est ce
qu'il y a lieu de s'alarmer jean paul
stahl je ne vois pas pour l'instant je
le vois pas de raison particulière
il est vrai que le lilia de l'épargnant
je suis l'africain c'est vrai on a
probablement pas l'explosion qui est
décrite dans les différents médias
tout simplement parce que l'explosion
des cas est lié aux déclarations en bloc
par les laboratoires qui ont fait les
tests donc à jour vous en avez zéro et
le lendemain vous en avez cent cinquante
six jeux si je schématise donc ça ne
correspond pas à une explosion c'est
simplement une explosion déclaration
ceci dit il est vrai que le virus
circule et y circulent de façon beaucoup
plus importante que dans d'autres cas
dans d'autres régions et y circulent
probablement depuis assez longtemps
puisque on ne retrouve pas de voyageurs
récents dans les contaminer diagnostiqué
récemment
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya eu une
contamination plus ancienne qui n'a pas
été diagnostiquée le virus depuis le
circuit donc ça c'est une c'est un fait
alors maintenant il ya effectivement
beaucoup plus de cas dans cette région
que dans d'autres régions
mais encore faut-il analyser le pourquoi
des choses c'est à dire à quoi sont dues
ces contaminations et à ma connaissance
mais j'ai pas la connaissance entière du
dossier de la moselle donc je me
contente de dire quelles sont les bases
la base c'est de savoir pourquoi est ce
que c'est les écoles peut-être encore
que
juste là on n'est jamais montré que les
écoles étaient des foyers de
contamination prioritaires et
primordiaux dans cette dans cette
épidémie
mais pourquoi pas est ce que ce sont les
ce que c'est le non-respect des mesures
barrières certainement puisque il n'y
aurait pas de contamination si les
mesures barrières étaient inspectés
est ce que il y à des conditions
particulières de type rassemblements qui
ont eu lieu ou je ne sais quoi encore
tout ça je ne sais pas mais ça doit être
explorées avant de prendre des mesures
radicales qui sont de mon point de vue
est vu d'un petit peu loin un petit pois
l'on porte on va on va écouter
abderrahim belghiti professeur
secrétaire général du sgen cfdt à ce
sujet justement les écoles les
établissements scolaires sont ils des
foyers de contamination à haut risque
selon vous pas par rapport à aux
expériences que vous avez écouté
effectivement l'association est créée et
surtout lorsqu'on se base des
déclarations de ministres de ligue et de
la santé plus de 300 cas pour les cent
mille habitants
effectivement la décision est tombée cet
après-midi conquois les écoles ne seront
pas fermées prend un conte a pris acte
de cette décision
sauf que maintenant il faut aussi être
vigilant et par rapport à tout ce qui
est les conditions de barrières et de
sanitaires pour les écoles et surtout
parce que jusqu'à présent normalement on
a autorisé des réunions de conseils de
classe des réunions de parents d'élèves
il faut se limiter maintenant à la
transmission de savoirs touriste que les
écoles restos restent ouverts pour cette
semaine
heureusement j'allais dire il ya une
semaine parce que effectivement après on
a les vacances oleko les collègues ils
vont souffler un petit peu et puis après
on espère que le rectorat prend des
mesures pas la veille de la rentrée
mais avant pour qu'on puisse se préparer
soi si la fermeture soit bien sûr de le
lancer les mots hybride et que les
collègues seront prêts pendant ses
vacances pour assumer la classe la
transmission de savoir et être auprès
des élèves
voilà ce que vous comprenez que
gouvernement ne suive pas les les
demandes justement de l'avis des élus et
des syndicats qui demandent la fermeture
des écoles les syndicats tous les
syndicats ne demandent pas de fermeture
des écoles
effectivement nous c'est celle d'été
sonné pour que les écoles soient reste
ouverte
tout simplement parce qu'on a remarqué
lors de premiers confinement qu'on a
laissés sur la marge
un certain nombre d'élèves normalement
qu'on a plus difficilement les récupérer
après donc ça c'est effectivement par
rapport à ces élèves qui sont j'allais
dire des femmes des familles d'élèves
défavorisés et qu'on peut être auprès de
2 maintenant la situe la situation et
les dramatiques effectivement il faut
prendre des décisions et parmi ces
décisions il faut renforcer le protocole
et surtout j'allais dire reste limitée
car la transmission de savoir et qu'on
se limite les réunions normalement qui
sont imposés dès fois par
l'administration
jean paul stahl est ce qu'on prend des
risques en france nous parce qu'on sait
que par exemple chez nos voisins
prochain de dégoût du grand test le
luxembourg et l'allemagne aussi la balle
et les écoles sont fermées
alors on peut renverser la question
pourquoi est ce que les allemands ferme
les écoles alors que les français les
laisse ouvertes
je veux dire c'est pas parce que c'est
en allemagne que signaux qui nous donc
simplement les mesures peuvent être
adaptés en fonction et à la culture des
pays concernés
il n'y a pas de compétition entre les
pays chacun fait en fonction de
l'épidémiologie qu'il a en face de lui
et qui est pas forcément la même
il est pas obligatoire que
l'épidémiologie à fribourg par exemple
soit la même que quand moselle je sais
pas du tout obligatoire
donc il ya des mesures qui sont adaptées
aux situations moi je vois ça je vois ça
comme ça alors les autorités de
recommence justement une renforcement de
de la politique des tests de la
vaccination reste à savoir les
protocoles qui sont mises en place est
ce que c'est suffisant par exemple au
niveau scolaire
abderrahmane belghiti oui effectivement
il ya des protocoles qui ont été mis
dans des établissements sauf que
malheureusement le timing normalement ne
le permet pas par rapport à aux
collègues c'est à dire le soir
l'établissement et se trouve un peu très
loin de l'établissement où ils sont
parce que c'est pas dans l'établissement
du collègue où ça se passe cette ce
dépistage
donc nous on ne demande donc que tous
les ans fin la multiplication de ces
dépistages mais au sein des
établissements ou bien de banaliser d
après midi pour les collègues puissent
aller se dépister qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire selon vous jean paul stahl pour
justement éviter la propagation trop
trop élargi de des variants il ya une
évidence c'est que un sujet porteur du
virus la transmet à ce sujet là secteur
et que si on respecte les mesures
barrières c'est à dire la distance et le
masque il est pas possible de
transmettre donc le simple bon sens
cd c'est de respecter les mesures tout
simplement qu'il s'agisse d'un variant
je suis d'africa anglais brésiliens ce
que vous voulez c'est la même chose
c'est sans les mesures barrières quand
on ne les respecte pas eh bien on
contaminée autour de soi quand on les
respecte
il n'y a pas de contamination autour de
soi alors justement le gouvernement
quand même il temporise tout cas c'est
ce qu'il donne l'impression avec
l'extension des variants dans grand test
dans le nord aujourd'hui donc quelle
attitude finalement il faut avoir face à
la propagation de ces variants sur le
territoire parce que on se dit aussi que
ça va s'étendre partout à un moment
donné c'est exactement ce que je vous
dis respect des mesures barrières et
d'être
encore plus attentifs en termes de
mesures barrières le viol le virus tombe
pas du ciel il n'est pas allé pas
véhiculés par je ne sais quoi qui vous
l'amènerai de façon impromptue
c'est un individu porteur autour de vous
qui moule à qui ou la transpi donc
mesures barrières mesures barrières et
encore mesures barrières c'est vraiment
la seule solution pour l'instant en
attendant une vaccination de masse mais
vous avez compris que il ya un problème
industriel derrière qui fait que ça ne
sera pas réglé en trois jours donc
mesures barrières mesures barrières et
encore mesure par dieu à défaut tout cas
d'une fermeture des établissements
scolaires
est ce qu'il ya des moyens qui vont être
mises en place pour justement permettre
aux établissements scolaires d'assurer
le protocole sanitaire efficient
abderrahmane belghiti pour le monde
normalement on n'a pas de l'information
du rectorat on a tous que c'est
normalement qui a effectivement ils vont
multiplier ce dépistage et nous on ne
demande aux effectivement que pour les
enseignants
un protocole de vaccination qui soit
pour protéger aussi voilà aujourd'hui
vous êtes inquiet par rapport à la
situation où vous dites finalement par
rapport à ce que le préfet de moselle a
annoncé le préfet du nord aussi bas mais
finalement il faut pas il faut pas
s'alarmer
l attitude il est là parce que parce que
on remarque que le taux d'incidents ce
ne serait ce que pour la moselle et les
2 300 et que effectivement un certain
nombre d'établissements
d'après les remontées de terrain sont
affectés et que certainement bout des
lèvres aussi des cas qui circulent
normalement de la moselle donc
effectivement on est inquiets le coréen
censée nous est acquis et effectivement
et qu'est ce qui nous attend et qu'est
ce qui nous attend jean paul stahl dans
les prochaines semaines les prochains
mois par rapport à l'évolution de ces
variants alors là bien malin est celui
qui peut le prédire
donc tu me lazhar devrait pas faire ça
je dis simplement qu'il ya c'est vrai
qu'il ya un risque simplement parce que
shiels épargnants sont plus contagieux
c'est parce que ils s'adaptent plus
facilement à l'espèce humaine donc ils
ont un avantage dans la compétition
entre virus
ils ont l'art et un avantage par rapport
aux autres pour infectées et affectées
les humains c'est le lot de ce genre de
ce genre de mutation ça arrive dans tous
les coups donc on peut s'attendre
effectivement à skis à ce qui se
répandent
est ce que c'est important j'en suis pas
si certain parce que encore une fois si
on arrive à respecter les mesures
barrières bama fois que ce soit variant
ou parer aux variants le résultat est
elle même il ne peut pas être transmis
donc je vais la question jean paul vous
insistez très près très fortement
justement est-ce qu'on est en mesure de
faire respecter les mesures barrières
aujourd'hui
et il ya un couvre-feu quotidien à 18h
les centres commerciaux qui sont fermés
le port du masque est généralisée
partout
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de plus
puisque pour l'instant les le
gouvernement écarte l'option d'un
confinement localiser et généralisée
encore une fois c'est pas le
gouvernement qui infecte les français
c'est pas une vidéo parce qu'il prend
les mesures c'est lui qui prend les
décisions
la solution et les duos des gens qui
infecte et donc c'est une meilleure un
meilleur respect des mesures par
ailleurs s'il ya 500 cas par jour ça
veut dire que ils ont été contaminés par
quelqu'un c'est pas c'est pas le
gouvernement harper désalpe rentabilité
ils ont été contaminés par quelqu'un et
il ya eu une faille dans les mesures
barrières
donc le problème il est chez chacun
d'entre nous dans notre responsabilité
individuelle vis-à-vis de ceux qui nous
entourent
c'est ça le vrai problème et c'est ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre il faut pas
qu'on veut qu'on se repose sur comme
traditionnellement l'obligation le
contrôle policier ou je ne sais encore
c'est qu'il faut bien comprendre que
chacun d'entre nous est responsable mais
juste l'inquiétude d'inquiétude des
français c'est aussi parce que ces
variants sont plus contagieux ça s'est
avéré
abderrahim belghiti justement est-ce que
les mesures de restrictions qui sont
pour l'instant décidé à ce que c'est
suffisamment efficace finalement le nom
sont pas efficaces et je prends pour
exemple que les basques normalement sont
payés sont payants et que effectivement
il faut que les rectorats normalement
alimente les établissements par ces
masques parce que au témoignage de pas
mal d'enseignants il ya des élèves qui
sont des mecs milieu des savoirs
défavorisés et qu'ils arrivent avec le
masque qu'ils ont peur depuis la semaine
et donc il faut que le rectorat
normalement alimente davantage les
établissements par les masques pour
respecter ces barrières sanitaires
voilà donc on aura bien compris ce que
vous nous dites est ce que j'en pense à
l'essai à
a bien rappelé et de respecter les
mesures barrières donc pour éviter donc
la propagation de ces variants merci à
vous merci abderrahmane belghiti
professeur secrétaire général du sgen
cfdt à boujan trusta l'infectiologue au
chu grenoble alpes